il ya beaucoup l'actu ce moment chez au
nord je vous ai parlé il ya quelques
jours je sais pas si vous vous en
souvenez aussi vous avez regardé ce
smartphone la selle au nord 9 x projet
réparer il ya quelques mois du nord 9 x
aulas de la différence province n'est
pas professionnel sans l'ancien vous
aviez services google sur celui-là vous
n'y avez pas vous avez la galerie donc
je vous invite à aller voir la vidéo
c'est pas déjà le cas si vous voulez
tout savoir sur les nouveautés sur
l'attitude et au nord vous a également
parlé d'un produit très cool c'est celle
là là c'est là honorent magic watch 2 ça
c'est là un modèle 46 mm c'est la
dernière mode connecté de honor plutôt
bien et aujourd'hui on va se parler d'un
produit au nord c'est celui-là c'est ça
et ça c'est intéressant je dis pas tu ne
le sont pas mais cela est encore plus
intéressant puisque c'est l'arrivée de
honor dans l'univers du pc en europe
avec ce produit là c'est le honor magic
book 14 pouces alors il existe une
version 14 pouces une version 15 pouces
ici on teste la 14 pouces la question à
se poser c'est est-ce que honor réussi
son arrivée en europe au niveau des pc
est déjà beaucoup de monde son marché
mais là il faut un truc qui est assez
intéressant c'est le tarif
j'ai tout de suite commencé par le tarif
est ensuite je vais vous parler de plein
de choses intéressantes sur ce produit
parce qu'il ya des choses qui sont
vraiment bien et d'autres qui sont un
peu moins bien mais vous allez barco
tarif auquel on ne le propose on peut
pas tout avoir mais c'est déjà vachement
bien
le tarif est normalement je fais ça leur
a mis le feu au début on est à 599 euros
avec 90 centimes il ya des offres
spéciales sur le site d honneur france
mais également sur amazon mais ça je
vous le dis à la fin de la vidéo
je vais tous vous donner au niveau du
tarif de vous détailler pendant qu'au
fils mort je vous ai demandé de
m'envoyer vos vidéos chez vous savoir
comment ça se passait chez vous à
l'adresse qui s'affiche ici amour @
monsieur groupe point fr on va donc se
visionner la vidéo d'aujourd'hui
salut à tous et à toutes je me noyer le
mois mais d'origine comorienne
et en ce moment je me trouvera au maroc
ça fait trois semaines qu'on est confiné
je fais est un petit coucou à messieurs
erreurs et restez chez vous et sauver
des vies donc moi je laisse à mes
secrets de nous présenter un bon augure
merci pour cette vidéo on va donc se
pencher sur ce honor magic book 14
pouces
on va regarder s'il était pour vous on
va regarder quels sont ses points
positifs ce qui va bien ce qui va un peu
moins bien quelles sont les limites
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec ac il se
destine et au final est-ce qu'il faut
l'acheter oui où nos premiers pôles fait
relever ça regardez là haut niveau 2 au
nord vous avez du bleu qui apparaît ça
s'est assez bien réussi très sympa
j'aime beaucoup autre point que j'aime
beaucoup au niveau du design c'est que
vous avez un liseré je passe on le voit
bien une fois de plus ce liseré bleu
qu'à faire tout le tour du produit vous
allez retrouver exactement tous les
côtés ça vient le type et ce en quoi on
un design qui est assez simple on a ici
un gris très classique qui fonctionne
très bien sur le dessous des grilles de
ventilation avec le ventilateur qu'on
devine qui très très bien ici les haut
parleurs qui sont planqués justice il
est petit patin patin là la connectique
on va la regarder dans quelques instants
un des points qui est cool et dire c'est
que vous pouvez l'ouvrir comme ça à 180
degrés alors qu'un intérêt me direz vous
et bien j'en ai pas forcément mais en
tout cas vous pouvez mettre comme vous
voulez en fonction de la position dans
laquelle vous allez être assis donc bon
pourquoi pas vous avez surtout
l'ordinateur qui est très léger qui fait
1 kg 38 qui est un châssis qui fait en
aluminium il existe en deux couleurs
mystic silver espèces gré le bouton
d'alimentation fait office de capteur
d'empreintes digitales et déverrouille
très rapidement pour moi la partie
design et très bien réussi au nord a
bien bossé sur cette machine est
maintenant qu en est il du point de vue
l'écran ici on a un écran lcd 14 pouces
résolution full hd 1920 par 1080 avec
une densité de pixels 257 pixels par
pouces un écran au format 16 9ème avec
un angle de vision de 178 degrés 178°
faut le dire vite pour moi la meilleure
position c'est vraiment lorsque vous
êtes devant dès que vous vous décaler un
peu surcoté
c'est un peu moins bien je vous cache
pas que si vous mettez comme ça vous
voyez quand même c'est pas complètement
optimale mais vous pouvez faire en gros
de la jusque là vous voyez à peu près
mais probablement confort optimal vous
mettez en face c'est là que vous aurez
la meilleure expérience vous avez un
écran qui est certifié lutter contre la
lumière bleue mais surtout vous avez une
luminosité maximale de 250 nits ce qui
fait que votre écran ne sera pas le plus
lumineux
lorsque vous allez venir l'utiliser en
extérieur et que vous avez beaucoup
lumière néanmoins pour l'utiliser en
intérieur et si vous êtes à l'extérieur
et vous avez pas un grand ciel bleu avec
beaucoup de soleil ça ira moins positive
vous avez des bords qui sont extrêmement
fin sur le haut mais également sur le
côté par contre sur le basket est un peu
plus grand ce qui vous permet d'avoir
des bords extrêmement fins et qui si
vous n'avez absolument pas de webcam
elle est planqué ici dans votre clavier
ça c'est bien en termes de sécurité vous
avez car appuyé et on la voit plus
maintenant le point négatif c'est que
vous êtes filmés par en dessous
c'est pas très glam par contre si vous
voulez voir les poils que vous avez dans
le nez et bien ce que je suis très très
très pratique ici c'est une caméra de 1
mégapixels on va pas avoir la meilleure
qualité mais je dirais pour me dire
contacté quelques amis bon pourquoi pas
au-delà de ça vous irait pas très loin
avec une fois de plus et compte tenu de
son prix je trouve que l'écran est bien
il tire légèrement sur le bleu donc si
vous voulez vous amuser à faire un petit
peu de retouches de photos vous allez
voir vais pas pouvoir aller bien loin là
dessus je vous l'expliquais dans
quelques instants mais si vous voulez en
faire un tout petit peu eh bien il faut
vraiment tenir compte du paramètre qu'il
tire un peu sur le bleu néanmoins je le
trouve honnête bien et on est vraiment
là dessus sur des usages bureautiques
messager vous détailler dans quelques
instants
qu'en est il maintenant de la partie
audio alors ici vous avez deux haut
parleurs le premier haut parleurs et
planck est là le deuxième haut parleurs
efflanqué là vous avez également deux
micros si vous voulez pouvoir discuter
avec un ami à distance faire du skype ce
que vous voulez et compagnie vous pouvez
le faire néanmoins qu'il faut vraiment
savoir là dessus c'est que la qualité
des haut parleurs ne sont pas
extraordinaires je vous fait écouter à
partir de pouvoir vous en rendre compte
les fréquences aiguës médiane est due à
aiguille on les perd on confie dans son
un peu tout fait médium grave si vous
montez le son ils vont avoir tendance à
saturer
mais quand on veut acheter un ordinateur
à un peu moins de 600 euros on va pas
non plus s'attendre à voir la meilleure
expérience audio donc si vous voulez
écouter un petit spotify en fond vous
pouvez le faire moi ce que je vous
conseille vraiment par contre message et
vous détaille dans quelques instants
si devenir branché ici un petit casque
et si vous voulez utiliser un casque
sans fil vous avez du bluetooth 5.0 pour
venir à péret votre casque extrêmement
facilement la partie performance ici
vous avez un processeur amd c'est le
raizen 5 3500 us vous avez 8 gigas de
ram ddr 4 à 2400 mégahertz et un ssd de
256 go en ssd un peu plus rapide que ce
qu'on pouvoir retrouver usuellement sur
du ssd donc c'est pas sur cette machine
là que vous allez stocker le plus de
choses c'est pas sur cette machine là
que vous allez avoir les meilleures
performances
j'ai pu ressentir ci et là quelques
ralentissements les applications mettre
un petit peu de temps à s'ouvrir mais
une fois de plus vous n'allez pas aller
sur cette machine avec 8 gigas de ram
pour des jeux puissant vous allez
l'utiliser pour du multimédia pour
naviguer sur internet regarder des films
et je vous conseille une fois de plus
d'utiliser la prise jack et elles sont
pas trop fort pour éviter de vous rendre
fou vous allez pouvoir travailler
collaborer créer mais crée oui mais pas
trop oublié les montages vidéo avec 8
gigas de ram ou alors vous faites un
petit clip de quatre minutes en 1080p
n'est pas plus oublier photoshop avec
plein de calques oublier lightroom ici
ça risque de ramer énormément et c'est
pas du tout l'adn de ce match de bout 14
est à noter que la carte graphique c'est
une radio vega 8 la question l'autonomie
c'est aussi un point très important et
très intéressant et si on a une batterie
de 56 water & honour nous annonce une
autonomie allant jusqu'à 10 heures en
bureautique
sauf que en fait les diseurs bureautique
je sais pas comment ils ont mesuré alors
j'imagine qu'ils les ont eues dans leur
laboratoire bien évidemment mais en
usage mixte vous êtes plus entre 6h et
6h30
mais les diseurs personnellement je n'ai
jamais eu alors ça dépend bien
évidemment de vous ça dépend de la
luminosité de votre écran ça dépend des
programmes que vous allez faire tourner
dessus donc l'autonomie va toujours un
peu varié mais je dirais que sur une
moyenne de 6 heures vous les aurez son
problème mais ce qui me paraît aussi
normal
par contre un truc est très bien c'est
qu'ici vous avez un chargeur de 65 watts
pour mir le chat rejetterait
demande si vous avez peu de temps devant
vous et vous manquez de charge eh bien
vous laisser un quart d'heure vingt
minutes une demi-heure c'est bien et
vous allez pouvoir repartir pour
quelques heures et pour une charge
complète il vous faudra deux heures pour
trouver un windows 10 aum
bon rien à dire d'exceptionnel là dessus
maintenant il ya un point qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est au nord magic
link je sais pas si ça vous dit quelque
chose aux normes hadji clics vous en ai
déjà parlé avec huawei c'est le système
huawei cher au nord fait partie du
groupe o weh et ils ont intégré cette
technologie dans cet ordinateur là et ça
c'est bien je vous montre où illustré ça
je vous ai pris un des derniers
smartphones de huawei c'est le web et 40
vous pouvez également prendre aux
smartphones récents de honor qui sera
parfaitement la faire dans votre
ordinateur vous avez sur l'application
pc manager dans pc manager vous venez
connecter votre téléphone vous
l'approchez et là votre smartphone est
connecté vous voyez donc votre
smartphone qui apparaît ici vous avez
toutes vos applications vous pouvez
venir naviguer très facilement prévenir
envoyer un message mais je dirais
surtout un des points les plus
intéressants par exemple ici je retrouve
une fleur est bien gardé gk venir poser
mon smartphone là et ma photo est envoyé
directement dans mon ordinateur dont je
veux bien partager très facilement des
photos de mon téléphone à mon ordinateur
mais l' inverse existe également par
exemple si un fichier word sur lequel
j'ai travaillé bon très sommairement
vous voyez ici
eh bien je pose mon smartphone elle
cocumont board est transférée
directement dans nos smartphone je peux
venir ouvrir et éditer très facilement
donc voyez ces fonctions partage apporte
vraiment quelque chose en plus à
l'expérience on est sur un écosystème
qui se dessine de plus en plus parce que
oui si on est sur la stratégie de honor
qui identique à celle de huawei un +8
plus n 1 et en votre smartphone le coeur
de votre écosystème l'objet
technologique que vous avez toujours
avec vous plus 8 sont les différentes
familles d'objets connectés que vous
avez autour de vous dans votre
ordinateur fait partie dans votre monde
fait bien évidemment partie
et elles sont tous les produits des
collaborateurs tiers vous allez avoir
autour c'est en tout cas l'idée fort que
vous avez en 2020 chez huawei mais
également chez oddo ici on trouve un
clavier azerty plutôt bien avec une cour
de touche que je trouve un peu longue
mais qui fondamentalement de pose
absolument aucun problème je trouve le
trackpad bien positionné avec une bonne
dimension par rapport à la taille du
châssis la navigation est très
confortable
maintenant il ya un point que j'ai
remarqué que je trouve un peu surprenant
c'est que bien évidemment vous avez vos
touches ici pour avoir le clic gauche
mais également le clic droit par contre
si vous appuyez fortement ailleurs ça
vient bouger et ça c'est assez bizarre
mais en fait vous le voyez vraiment ici
mange pas si vous vous en rendrez compte
sept parties du châssis bouge quand même
assez facilement alors il n'y a
absolument aucun intérêt
appuyez ici mais voyez bien petit rebond
qu'on vient retrouver ici et qu'on
retrouve au niveau de son trackpad
rien de bien déconnant sur l'utilisation
ça pose absolument aucun problème par
contre effectivement la petite touche
toutes les liens non il faut venir
appuyer un peu plus pour la voir à voir
si à l'usagé pas les petites choses que
venir se cacher ici ou se mettre ici à
côté de ça je trouve très réactif et il
fait bien à faire au niveau de la
connectique j'ai retrouvé de l'usbc de
l'usb 3.0 du hdmi mais également de
l'usb 2.0 une prise jack 3.5 pour de la
brancher votre casque si on fait bien
branché un moniteur externe hdmi vous
pouvez le faire donc une fois de plus ça
c'est cool
maintenant il ya un point à savoir s'est
pas réellement un bémol ça aurait été
bien qu'ils aient deux ports usb sait
puisque votre chargeur fonctionne en usb
c'est ce qui fait que si vous le changez
vous allez occuper le port usb c'est
vous n'allez donc pas pouvoir brancher
un disque dur externe par exemple en usb
c'est il va donc falloir attendre votre
ordinateur soit chargée pour pouvoir le
faire c'est vraiment histoire de
chipoter puisque je trouve que la
connectique est plutôt bonne là dessus
maintenant la question et actis des
styles cet ordinateur au nord est une
marque qui cible un public plutôt jeune
et là dessus s'est affirmée ils vont
venir chercher des étudiants des jeunes
actifs des personnes qui veulent un
ordinateur cohérent qui vous permettra
de venir travailler de faire de la
bureautique de venir regarder quelques
films séries avec netflix youtube tout
ce que vous voulez être l'audio est un
petit peu en somme et si vous utilisez
un casque sera parfaitement le boulot
qu'on va pas voir une machine
extrêmement puissant pour bien faire
tourner beaucoup de jeux dessus c'est
pas un ordinateur qui n'ont pu destiné
aux créatifs photoshop première et
compagnie c'est pas sur cette machine là
qu'il faut vous dirigez mais si vous
voulez travailler avec le pack office
si vous voulez faire du traitement de
texte voulait faire de limeil louis fin
de la prise de notes que vous êtes à la
fac que vous leur ordinateur pour gérer
le quotidien à la maison et bien cette
machine là est vraiment bien très bien
positionnés et peuvent vraiment venir
vous correspond comme je le disais c'est
l'ordinateur qui coûte 599 euros 1,90 et
il ya des offres qui sont vraiment
intéressantes si vous voulez acheter sur
le site de honor d'ailleurs vous avez un
petit lien en bas d'un description
pouvez cliquer les stocks du coup d'oeil
vous allez voir c'est quand même plutôt
pas mal et bien au nord vous offre cette
montre là celle que je vous ai montré le
jour c'est là honorent magic watch deux
ans 46 mm il faut quand même savoir
qu'il coûte un peu moins de 100 euros
199 euros 90 et ça c'est une offre que
vous avez jusqu'au 28 avril 2020 et si
vous voulez acheter chez amazon vous
n'avez pas de cadeau mais par contre
vous avez une offre de remboursement de
100 euros jusqu'au 10 mai
2020 autant vous dire que cette bécane
vous fait de l'oeil c'est maintenant une
fois de plus je vous mets les liens en
bas dans la description ce qui fait que
si vous l'achetez sur amazon vous la
payez pas 599 190 vous la payez 499
euros 90 et si vous posiez la question
vous achetez une belle monde connecté
allez faire un tour directement sur le
site de honor puisque vous allez avoir
une montée couteau mais pas moins de 200
euros
autant vous dire que là il se moque pas
de vous trouve que au nom réussit bien
son entrée dans le monde du pc de
l'ultra portable avec une machine qui
est somme toute assez cohérente il va
pas être la machine la plus performante
qui néanmoins sera bien sur toute la
ligne
dans la mesure où vous restez sur des
usages de bureautique
a vous de me dire vous comment vous la
trouvez vous le remarquez bien
évidemment en bas en commentaire est ce
que vous pourriez pente et sens je vous
embrasse donne rendez vous demain pour
continuer à parler tech avec des gros
bisous cacao
[Musique]